regardez il ne s'est pas trompé après la
décrue dans le quartier du groupe c de
rambouillet les vivre un fonds l'état
des lieux dans ce garage ginette
entreposer tout son matériel pour les
brocantes des objets qu'elle est obligée
aujourd'hui de jeter
c'était le ghana on faisait des vide
greniers on faisait quand même de
prendre vide greniers on travaillait
bien elle est de droite à gauche on
vendait bien là on peut dire on peut on
jette
aucun objet dit de valeur ou
d'électroménager il est donc difficile
de chiffrer le montant pour les
assurances une perte sèche pour cette
retraitée qui n'a pas pris la peine de
les contacter pour éviter la tente d'un
expert et sauver ce qu'elle pouvait
conserver pour certains habitants du rez
de chaussée de la rue de la motte c'est
leur appartement entier qui a été
envahie par les eaux j'étais pas assurée
pour la maison donc madame arthur c'est
le ccrs qui maquille marc logé à partir
de vendredi et dans une chambre dans une
chambre d'hiver ce qu'ils appellent à
une chambre divers qui guiraud loges
qu'ils hébergent les laissant appris
pendant l'hiver officialisé ce jeudi au
journal officiel l'état de catastrophe
naturelle devrait accélérer les
démarches d'indemnisation pour les
assurés j'ai téléphoné à mon assureur
qui a fait appel après un expert dès le
mercredi matin en fait tu es mon
assureur est passé hier après midi
donc voila tout s'est bien passé on nous
demande des factures après évidemment
hong a pas tous nos factures c'est très
rare même et du coup on donne la date le
montant estimé et puis une facture si on
a sinon ballon sans facture des photos
devraient suffire aux assureurs grâce à
l'état de catastrophe naturelle sur
l'ensemble de la commune c'est environ
300 dossiers que la mairie accompagner
dans les démarches administratives